yeah I don't hate any group I like all
the groups you know I also like racial
jokes yeah those kind of went away
I know I grew up in a predominantly
black neighborhood I went to public
school we'd all say horrible things to
each other everybody got along now you
can't make those jokes anymore and we're
seeing more tense than ever it was fun
cut the tension you know I walked to
school they'd be like Mark you can't
dance I was like well you can't swim
we're all still friends of this day then
you get around some stiff white guys
like hey you can't say that I'm like we
don't we don't know our relationship
that's what we do like you walk in on me
choking my wife you're like call the
police like now she loves that huh
you don't always know the relationship